[Music]
not anymore nicki minaj reveals she's
sober and loving life i'm a bad [ __ ]
this is crazy on thursday the 39 year
old rapper tweeted quote i used to be
happy when i was high now i'm happy when
i'm sober no judgment to anyone before
sharing a little advice with our fans
quote be gentle with yourself i know
that's gonna pay off nikki's
announcement comes shortly after she
shared this clip frying chicken when i
be saying like oh sag this or whatever
like i i really was flying chicken [ __ ]
so all sagittariuses which probably um
frying chicken today
look no no no no no no no no wait wait
wait no blood
because i got water and then i just put
my up
so what y'all talking about that'd be
some real y'all be laughing that's that
yeah that had some followers wondering
if nicki had the munchies in fact one
fan straight up asks quote baby are you
high to which the anaconda rapper
sweetly replies no i'm sober and loving
life you i always want to be great at
anything i do nikki's fans aka the barbs
are now praising her from making the
healthy change and sharing her journey
writing things like respect for this
realness and calling her authenticity
and honesty so inspiring
well that was that's always the goal and
it seems nikki may have dropped a hint
last month after releasing her track we
go up i know they sleeping on me [ __ ]
[Music]
those lyrics are a far cry from the ones
she wraps on trey song's 2010 hit
bottoms up which includes nods to
basically all the boozy beverages
can i get that honey could i get that
mug if you don't want to rock rock box
could i get sold all around
nikki's also been known to talk about
smoking marijuana tweeting back in 2017
quote this weed had the clouds turning
into actual people and they were doing
things they were moving around and had a
life of their own like humans and in
2009 she joked that smoking weed was out
of style sarcastically writing whoa do
people still smoke weed so 10 years ago
as if
so not fetch well not for my barbies
anyway well seems like nikki has changed
her tune and we're here for it of course
the musician who is married to kenneth
petty welcomed a baby boy in 2020 whom
she affectionately calls papa bear
you say hi
i rap and sing to him all the time i
just make i just make up melody all day
and she recently opened up about how
motherhood has changed her during
carpool karaoke with james corden when i
look at my son
i'm like just magically in love you know
he just makes me laugh makes me smile
makes me happy like he's just so cute
and cuddly
[Music]